it's Michelle from lab muffin beauty science
chemistry PhD skincare nerd and tretinoin fan
today I'm going to be talking about how
to start on tretinoin adapalene and other
powerful retinoids tretinoin is one of the
most science-based skin care ingredients but
it's notoriously hard to start on there's
lots of peeling and irritation involved
and I might have gotten broken capillaries
from the first time I tried retinol there's
even a technical name for this break-in period
retinisation so to help you start on it and to
avoid all the mistakes I made here are some
tips on how to add it to your routine with
minimal side effects so you can get the
benefits without freaking out your skin
if you like this sort of video give it
a thumbs up subscribe to my channel and
make sure you click the nerdification
bell so that you don't miss any videos
retinoids are vitamin a derivative for example
tretinoin retinol differin which is adapalene
and tazarotene they're really popular ingredients
in skincare and it's also in accutane which is
isotretinoin an oral medication they have very
powerful anti-aging anti acne and anti pigment
effects and there are lots of scientific studies
to back them up the main drawback to these Holy
Grail skincare ingredients is irritation this
means dry flaking peeling skin stinging and
redness this usually happens in the first few
weeks until your skin eventually gets used to
it some people don't get this irritation at all
and for some people it takes up to six weeks to
stop out of the retinoids tretinoin is one of
the most irritating but the benefits are also
best supported by the evidence tazarotene is more
irritating but adapalene retinol and retinaldehyde
are less irritating I was particularly scared
to start on retinol because back when I tried
1% retinol I went a bit too hard I have pretty
resilient skin and nothing really hurts it and it
recovers really quickly not so much with retinol
I used too much too quickly my skin is actually
quite sensitive to it and this irritation has
a bit of a delay it doesn't happen the next day
it happens the day after so it's a bit harder to
adjust how much I use based on my skin's feedback
and you need to have some self-control which
I don't really have I also had a cold at the
time and so I blew my nose a lot and I think the
combined irritation gave me broken capillaries
since retinoids increased skin irritation they
can also cause purging which is when a product
makes your skin worse before it gets better
because basically it makes your skin expel all
the baby pimples that were there much faster
I have a video on how to tell if your skin is
purging or breaking out and whether to stop your
product or to wait until it blows over purging is
worse when your skin's irritated so it's best
to add the tretinoin slowly so that your skin
can adjust the two main ways to limit how purgey
your skin gets is to introduce the product slowly
and to look after your skin and so that's the
aim of my tips here retinoid products tend to
come in lots of different percentages and it's
recommended that you start with a formula that's
this gentle as possible so for example you can
look for lower concentrations and time-release
cream formulas are also more gentle than gels and
they also tend to be more effective at delivering
the medication to your skin as well there are a
few different strategies for adding retinoids and
slowly basically you want to put it in as low as
possible without losing patience some strategies
are using a lower concentration of building it
up so you can use the lower concentration in
the formula or you can try to dilute it with
oil or cream you can also try alter in a day
application which is pretty self-explanatory
just use it every second day or third day at
first there's also short contact therapy which is
where you apply the product like a mask and rinse
it off there's a few studies where short contact
gave good results in one study on acne a daily
0.05 percent tretinoin cream applied for half an
hour gave comparable results to leaving it on and
a lot less people about 20% had irritation even
without a moisturizer other considerations include
using mild skincare so using gentle cleansers
and moisturizers and avoiding things like acid
exfoliants while your skin is getting used to
the retinoid you should also try not to apply the
retinoid while your skin's wet because it's easier
for ingredients to penetrate wet skin so after you
cleanse wait about half an hour before you apply
it it also helps if you apply the product evenly
you tend not to apply very much and so you want to
spread it out over your skin so you don't end up
with hot spots one technique is to jot it around
your face and rub it in you can also dilute it
with a cream or moisturizer and then put it on
as well I'm using my routine as an example that
you can follow or you can adapt at your own
needs the product I started with was no point
not 5% tretinoin or retinoic acid the brand name
is retin-a but I used a generic version which in
Australia is $30 for 25 mL which is much cheaper
than most non prescription retinoids and it's
a lot better regulated so it has a much better
chance of working the way it's intended for the
first week I did short contact therapy with half
an hour in the evening three days apart I used two
half pea-sized amount each time and washed it off
with a gentle cleanser I used really gentle skin
care like a humectant toner moisturizer I tried
stratia liquid gold and dr. jart cicapair cream
and I found that cicapair was more effective for
my first week I had zero irritation or peeling and
only a little bit of dryness but I also didn't
really have any results although I didn't get
any new pimples so the next week I stepped it
up so the second week I left it on my skin but
I applied an oil underneath I put a really thick
layer of oil so something like stratia fortify or
huxley secret of Sahara oil light and oil and
then I applied about a quarter pea amount on
my face though all helped the cream spread around
really evenly and I used to moisturizer afterwards
so the same ones from the first week on the days I
wasn't using tretinoin I used a humectant toner or
a really weak AHA product this is when the peeling
really started there was a lag time of about a day
and a half and so i would start peeling in the
middle of the day and it would clear up after
about a day there was also a bit of dryness and
some mild stinging one tip for makeup if your
skin's peeling is to just use concealer rather
than foundation because it makes the flakes look
a bit less obvious by this time I was meant to get
a few big pimples around this time of the month
but I didn't get any which was nice but it could
have also been a fluke I also noticed that some
post inflammatory hyperpigmentation was fading a
bit faster than usually would because that meant
quite well for the next two weeks I applied the
tretinoin to bare skin every third day I used
to quarter pea-sized amount and I put it on dry
skin and I tried to keep it away from areas that
get really irritated and flaking so around my nose
and around my chin I put moisturizer on afterwards
and I used a weak alpha hydroxy acid product the
night before for these two weeks I started with
some irritation but by the end I pretty much had
no irritation or peeling by the end of week four
I could use the tretinoin every second day I've
talked about my final routine in detail on my
blog which I've also linked in the description but
here's the gist of it I have a three day schedule
which rotates on the first night I use a quarter
to half pea-sized amount of tretinoin on the other
days I alternate between alpha hydroxy acid and
vitamin C and I use niacinamide on all the nights
I found that this was the best combination for
me in terms of results I found that tretinoin
really helps with the texture of my skin so how
smooth it is how big my pores are it also helps
with how my skin looks so it's a lot clearer and a
lot glowier and this is probably down to the fact
that tretinoin makes your stratum corneum more
compact this is the layer of dead skin cells on
top of your skin I have found though that I still
need alpha hydroxy acid to keep the clogged pores
in check and I still need vitamin C to fade
the hyperpigmentation much faster I found that
with this routine I don't get much irritation or
flaking while I still get all the benefits of the
ingredients I made a lot of mistakes when I first
started so I'm listing them here so you don't make
them too my first mistake was using way too much
way too often this is a really easy mistake to
make especially if your skin is generally quite
resilient treat it like it's kryptonite mistake
number two is using the retinoids and then using
other irritating things like alpha hydroxy acids
next I accidentally used 10% alpha-hydroxy
acid during week two and the next day I had
the tightest and most stinging face when I
was applying basic things like sunscreen and
foundation five percent was okay for me at the
beginning 10 percent became okay for me later on
but at the start just don't do it I also made
the mistake of using a humectant toner before
applying the retinol at the beginning and later
on every less this made my skin more permeable
and more prone to stinging so I hope you found
this video useful if you did give it a thumbs up
and you can subscribe to my channel for more
videos like this you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin beuaty science and check
out my blog for more nerdery see you next time